vous pu
empêcher le président monsieur le
ministre selon les sondages le ministre
de l'intérieur à qui s'adressait ma
question est promis à un avenir flatteur
pour certains matignon serait à sa
portée pour d'autres les portes de
l'elysée lui serait de grandes ouvertes
alors pourquoi s'est il engagé dans une
opération particulièrement manipulatrice
de découpage de l'ensemble des
départements la loi relative à
l'élection des conseillers
départementaux a été votée dans la
douleur
278 députés et sénateurs l'ont approuvé
soit 38 % des votants alors que 444 ont
voté contre soit 62% le gouvernement
était sauvé par la constitution donnant
le dernier mot à l'assemblée nationale
cette loi pose deux grands principes la
parité l' équilibre démographique ces
principes sont actés et une est plus
nécessaire que voulait comme entier je
souhaiterais vous interroger sur la
méthode employée pour découper monsieur
valls affirmait s'il n'y a pas de
critère c'est la loi de la jungle il a
donc pris des engagements forts il a été
comme à l'habitude ferme précis voire
autoritaire de plus il tient la plume en
rédigeant les décrets et les ciseaux en
découpant à sa guise il nous a dit la
représentation des territoires est une
nécessité notamment dans les
départements à fort caractère rural des
cantons trop étendu serait absurde la
superficie et le nombre des communes
seront donc prises en compte les
territoires ruraux seront mieux
représentés d'autant que les
intercommunalités seront intégrés
associés sont modestes non à une
révolution tout en conservant la
dimension rurale c'est un motif de
fierté nous disait-il aucun de ses
engagements par huit ans d'eau a été
tenue noms des 52 avis déjà rendu par le
conseil les conseils généraux ainsi que
les milliers de délibération de communes
que vous êtes bien gardé de consulter
mais qui s'expriment sont édifiants voir
cinglant il constate majoritairement
tous bords confondus que vous étouffer
la ruralité et que vous jouez les
bassins de vie et des intercommunalités
évoquant les services publics et
notamment les gendarmeries monsieur
valls annonçait je souhaite envisager
une réorganisation des services publics
en tenant compte de la carte cantonale
est ce à dire que divisant par deux le
nombre de cantons vous allez diviser par
deux la présence des services publics
les citoyens apprécieront
j'en viens à ma question monsieur le
ministre tiendra vous compte des avis
des conseils généraux avez vous
l'intention de publier en bloc dans la
deuxième quinzaine de février les 98
décret vous permettant ainsi de
paralyser la réaction des conseils
généraux parmi les milliers de recours
qui viendront de tous bords au delà du
1er mars le conseil d'état pourrait
procéder à quelques annulations
prendrez-vous de nouveau décret quitte à
ne pas respecter la loi de 90 pouvez
vous nous préciser à moins de deux mois
de l'échéance que les règles sur les
comptes de campagne pourront fonctionner
maîtrisez-vous la situation nouvelle
issue de cette loi source de contentieux
envisagez-vous si nécessaire de revoir
la date des élections ou de faire voter
une nouvelle voie madame lebranchu nous
a dit mardi le gouvernement une
interprétation sur série terminée une
interprétation n'est ce pas une
aberration juridique et politique merci
monsieur le ministre alain vidalis
chargé des relations avec le parlement
mais merci monsieur le président
monsieur le sénateur il n'y a pas de
lois votées dans la douleur il n'y a que
des lois de la république et c'est la
loi de la république que nous allons
appliquer avec les principes qui sont
les principes qui ont été données par le
conseil constitutionnel vous avez
combattu cette loi vous l'avez dit
vous-même ce n'est pas le moment d'y
revenir mais vous l'aviez combattu vous
êtes steam y est même qu'elle n'était
pas constitutionnelle tout ça est
derrière nous c'est bien la loi de la
république validée par le conseil
constitutionnel et qui obéit à des
principes que vous n'avez pas rappeler
je comprends votre discrétion sur ces
questions là mais l'objectif principal
qui a amené au choix de ce système c'est
enfin d'avoir une représentation de la
parité dans les conseils département
dans votre département du loiret il y a
aujourd'hui cette femme qui sont
conseillère départementale
je pense que vous pouvez vous féliciter
avec dos c'était l'objectif de la loi
demain il y aura vingt-et-une femmes
dans le conseil général du loiret dans
votre département l'écart entre le plus
petit canton est le plus important est
de 1 à 5 eh bien demain chaque voix dans
votre département mais partout en france
comptera de la même manière c'est
l'objectif du redécoupage avec les
critères
démographique l'est la jurisprudence du
conseil constitutionnel comme celle du
conseil d'état vous donne toutes les
garanties je ne reprends pas ce que j'ai
déjà répondu précédemment monsieur
marseille mais ces règles elles sont
précises elles sont hiérarchisées même
au delà d'ailleurs de ce que l'on avait
pu comprendre et notamment la règle
prioritaire étant celle de l' équilibre
démographique vous pouvez prendre
connaissance des observations du conseil
d'état y compris sur les propositions de
redécoupage qui sont faites par le
ministère de l'intérieur donc ce
redécoupage il se fait dans la clarté
dans une procédure qui est une procédure
transparente et vous me permettrez de
vous dire que lorsque vous étonner de
ses objectifs de ce redécoupage je me
permets simplement de vous rappeler que
ce que vous souhaitiez faire c'est à
dire de m un conseiller territorial qui
viendrait remplacer les conseillers
départementaux et les conseillers
régionaux ça aboutisse est exactement à
la même nécessité du même redécoupage
avec les mêmes conséquences est
exactement les mêmes critères permettez
moi de vous le rappeler et enfin je veux
au nom du ministère de l' au ministre de
l'intérieur m'inscrire en faux sur ce
que vous avez rappelé malheureusement
pour vous dire qu'il n'y a strictement
aucun lien entre le redécoupage cantonal
ou la circonscription cantonales et
l'implantation des services publics
c'est totalement faux de véhiculer cette
idée qu à l'occasion du redécoupage il y
aurait une remise en cause merci public
le merci ce de l'intérieur s'inscrit en
faux contre cette affirmation merci la
parole est à laurence rossignol pour le
groupe socialiste